I read somewhere that you're a huge
football fan and I don't know is that
how every year I try to wean myself off
cuz I know it's wrong but I can't stop
why is it wrong it's not wrong to be a
popular you know like hurt yeah I love
it yeah yeah so how intense are you when
it comes to football you a casual it
sounds like you're a casual of yours
well I'm not casual I mean I really
watch every weekend and you know I I
think I like the rituals of it I like
the you know I like the outfits and the
face painting and I listen the face
painting I did you get into the face
painting
have you ever painted have you ever like
gotten your face painted before I well I
did once yeah I was a kid's birthday
party and I'm just shoved a couple of
those three-year-olds aside like I want
some of that Ryan for a while that I
just you know I I love that idea yeah
that you just cut a head please okay
I've got a star in the Hollywood Walk of
Fame right there
get out paint my face little Green Bay
GE and Green Bay but you're from hey
snow booing in this studio
unless it's during my monologue you're
from Los Angeles how did you become a
Green Bay we didn't really have a team
until about five minutes ago
right so but how did you choose Green
Bay I mean did you just sort of like
spin of waifus you chosen for the
outfits I like yeah that's my friend
Karen has all the cheese she has lots of
cheese heads and cheese memorabilia and
I have a cheese beer holder and I got
cheese everything that's so funny that's
so random I would never think of you
wearing it wearing a cheese head you
know you know you just don't know me I
guess really if I just rang your
doorbell you open the door you might be
wearing what I might be I love that yeah
um but I'm you know kind of fickle I go
from team to team and if they're doing
really badly I abandon them and move on
love that that's the perfect thing to do
I like what I like to do is I really get
involved if my team is in the
championship or getting near it I get
involved rights but I don't want to get
emotionally involved until they're doing
pretty well right because I fail your'e
yes I want that like What's My Children
- I'm gonna wait and see how they turn
out and then you're gonna start
supporting them yeah when my wife tells
me no no this one looks like it boy
during the break the prop Department
brought this out for you
[Music]
[Applause]
this is not this is really this is real
what's that
yes sure I'll do the way Vidya this is
not how I thought my interview with
Jodie Foster would end but it did I'm
absolutely delighted thank you so much
for being here congratulations on
you